[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
true detective has just wrapped up its
third season and whilst it may not be
the ending that fans of the franchise
were seeking it still betrays just how
complex life can be throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the finale
as well as what happened to the
characters there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything from the highly suggests that
you turn off now but with that out the
way I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I explain it so you don't
have to
HBO's true detective season 3 centers
around the kidnapping of Julie and
Wilbur sell his sister Julie's
disappearance becomes the mystery that
the show pivots around and ultimately it
is our protagonist Wayne Hayes obsession
the show jumps from timeline to timeline
to showcase that in the end the only
real thing that can bring answers is the
passage of time similar to the way the
show works we must wait with the
characters until all of the right
elements fall into place to get the
answers that we've been searching for
after 35 years in the case we discover
that it was in fact Isabelle Hoyt a
mentally ill woman that kidnapped the
children after building a friendship
with them the fateful day that they
disappeared Isabelle attempted to bring
Julie home with her however will fall
back which ultimately led to his
accidental death working with her
caretaker Isabelle was able to hide his
body but she did not want to let go of
Julie Julie was drugged for years and
kept in the pink room with Isabelle
eventually hoping to adopt the girl Lucy
Julie's mother in fact knew about all of
this but kept quiet after being paid off
officer Harris too fell victim to his
Abele's fortune and this is why he
framed others to take the fall for the
case
Julie managed to escape from the heights
with help from the caretaker after she
began remembering her life before the
events while it's reportedly Julie died
of HIV Adnan's
Wayne believed this to be a cover-up
Hayes manages to track Julie down
eventually surmising that she probably
got together with her former schoolmate
and had a daughter
however when Wayne arrives to where he
now suspects that Julie lives his memory
slips away and he forgets the reason why
he's there Hayes isn't able to close the
case but that doesn't mean it's a sad
ending as he still manages to reconnect
both West and his own children which is
some small victory the final shot shows
Wayne is a trucker in Vietnam as he
heads off into the jungle it appears
that he's once again searching for
something this sums up Wayne's entire
arc as the character was always looking
for something rather than being content
with the answers he was able to attain
in the end he never gets the answers
that he was looking for instead he just
continues searching and able to see that
the truth was in front of him the whole
time
in conclusion this entire season has
been centered around how power can often
pressure the truth into not being
revealed the power that the heights had
enabled them to hide a secret about
Julie for decades allowing for the light
to continue however lies are not always
a bad thing either the lies that Julie
kept up after escaping or what enabled
her to be happy and this is reflected in
ultimately how Wayne is enabled to an
earth of the truth obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the finale and if
he took anything different from it if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of the trailer for The
Twilight Zone which would be linked up
at the end this is a channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best not see you next
time take care peace
[Music]